Ça y est !
Le moment est venu !
Je peux enfin vous en parler !
Les amis aujourd'hui je vais vous parler du plus gros projet de l'histoire
pas de ma chaîne YouTube parce que c'est pas un projet vidéo
mais de ma carrière
Oh le mec il a une carrière et tout comme il se la pète !
Tout d'abord ce n'est pas que mon projet
Y'a plein de gens qui ont bossé là-dessus
Mais l'idée est née en juillet 2014
Quand après avoir fait plusieurs lives sur Cyprien Gaming
Cyprien me dit:
Et si on fessait une Web TV avec tout les gens qu'on kiffe ?
Ah, pourquoi pas ouais !
Super allez tu t'en occupes au revoir !
Bah tu vas...t'es..oh le roumain !
Non c'est faux pardon, c'est faux il a trouvé le nom et pour ça il a dû durement travailler
Le stream.
Merci Cyprien pour ta participation sur ce projet !
Non je rigole je caricature il a quand même vachement aidé j'en fais des caisses mais voilà j'ai envie de le vanner
Alors leStream c'est quoi ?
Connaissez vous Twitch, connaissez vous le live sur Internet ?
Vous connaissez peut être ZeratoR, Skyyart, Jiraya, DominGo, AlphaCast, Gotaga et y'en a plein d'autre!
*bruit d'explosion*
Ce sont des streamers, des gens qui jouent aux jeux vidéos en live sur internet
Et quand des streamers se regroupent pour proposer différents programmes
à différentes plages horaires, ça donne une Web TV
Et LeStream.fr qu'est-ce que c'est ?
c'est une Web TV
Ça remonte très très loin mais on avait vraiment l'envie de faire un projet avec tous les gens qu'on aime
qu'on a été amener à croiser ou voir même à travailler avec pour certain
on s'est dit : Putain mais ces gens sont trop cool, on aime trop ce qu'ils font, ils sont hyper sympa
et il faut vraiment qu'on bosse ensemble plus que ça quoi, qu'on fasse plus souvent des trucs ensemble
en bonne ambiance, pas forcément sur des jeux vidéos, mais voilà, on avait cette envie de faire des trucs avec
et sur YouTube, bah j'ai envie de faire des vidéos où j'suis parfois avec des gens mais aussi souvent quand j'suis seul
Donc fallait faire un truc en plus
Et c'est là que vous êtes contents parce que ça fait plus de contenus pour vous
Vous êtes pas contents, c'est alors que le lancement est raté
On s'est alors mis à contacter tout ses gens qu'on appréciait, de près ou de loin
Et à leur proposer le projet, à leur dire : "les gars venez on fais une Web TV tous ensemble, ça va être génial"
Bon on a dû plus developper que ca parce que sinon ils nous aurait dis non mais bon
Et on a été super content parce que tout ces gens ont accepté
Mais c'était y'a 2 ans..
*rire*
Le site a mis énormément de temps a être fait mais du coup parlons du site
Qu'est ce que vous pouvez retrouver sur ce site ?
Eh ba comme je vous ai dis ya la WebTv, c'est la chaine principale du site
C'est de 12h jusqu'a 2h du mat tous les jours
Ça commence à 12h et ca finit dans la nuit et chaque jours ca recommence à 12h et ca finit dans la nuit
Et selon les heures il y a différentes emissions qui vous sont proposées avec différentes personnes
Par exemple de 12h à 14h ça peut être quelqu'un qui fais du jeu video
De 14h à 16h ça peut être plusieurs mecs qui vont faire des jeux de société.
Il y a de tout!
Du jeux video, pas du jeux video, du talk show, du sport..
Il y aura vraiment de tout sur cette web tv
Parce qu'on a voulu rendre ca accessible
Et on surtout voulu que ca plaise aussi aux gens qui n'aiment pas forcement regarder quelqu'un jouer aux jeux video pendant des heures
Même si moi j'adore ça
Et en plus de cette Web TV qui commence tout les jours a 12h et qui finit dans la nuit
Et qui recommence le lendemain a 12h comme je l'ai dit
Et qui re-finit....*rires*
Insupportable! xD
Vous pourrez retrouver toute l'équipe sur leurs onglets perso
Par exemple, une fois que j'ai fini mon emission de 12h à 14h le lundi,
Si j'ai encore envie de streamer ba vous pouvez me retrouver sur mon onglet perso sur le site.
tous les onglets sont reliés à Twitch,
c'est des chaines Twitch
mais vous avez intérêt à passer par le site LeStream.fr , pourquoi ?
Pour des petites fonctionnalités cool qu'on a mis au point avec Mikalo
Alias le bâtard qui me bat à tous les jeux video auxquels on joue depuis maintenant 5 ans.
J'espère que ces petites fonctionnalités supplémentaires vous plairons,
En tout cas croyez moi vous avez vraiment intérêt a passer par LeStream.fr
Et en plus, c'est plus beau que Twitch
Ah ba oui on s'est fait chier hein !
Ça a pas mis 2 ans à sortir pour rien mon gars !
Et là vous avez peut-être deja cliqué sur le site
Et vous êtes très déçu parce qu'il y a un compte a rebours
Le site n'est pas encore ouvert, il ouvre mercredi à 17h
1h avant la toute premiere emission du site :
Le Prime
Ouais "Le Stream" donc "Le Prime"
Donc "Le Échec" si ça vous plait pas aussi
Qu'est ce que c'est Le Prime ?
C'est une émission qui va durer entre 1h30 et 2h qu'il y aura chaque mercredi en début de soirée
Normalement les primes ce sera à 20h mais le premier on l'a avancé à 18h parce que mercredi 8 mars ya quoi ?
Ya PSG-Barça à 20h45
PSG-Barça ca fais quoi ?
Ca fais que les petits abonnés qui t'aiment et qui t'adorent,
D'un coup te tourne le dos comme ça et disent :
"Nique les youtubeurs, vas-y mets un but!"
Vous avez raison..le sport c'est kiffant
Bref Le Prime c'est quoi ?
C'est une émission dans laquelle il y aura toute l'équipe Le Stream.
D'ailleurs j'ai toujours pas dit les noms, ça arrive...
Deux chefs d'équipe vont être nommés et vont choisir qui seront dans leur equipe.
Et ensuite ces 2 équipes vont s'affronter à travers diverses épreuves
Bon il est temps de vous dire quels copains on accepté de rejoindre le projet
Et je les remercie de tout mon coeur parce que ça va être absolument génial.
Maxildan, Mikalo, Gotaga, Xari, Jiraya, CodJordan, Cyprien, Skyyart, Nems, Zankio, Manami, Zoulou et Trinity
*applaudissements*
Un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour eux
Soyez présent mercredi à 17h pour l'ouverture du site
Et mercredi à 18h pour le tout premier stream de LeStream.fr
On vous a concocté vraiment des trucs sympa,
J'espère que ca va vous plaire, soyez present
Et en attendant n'hésitez pas à aller follow la chaine Twitch LeStream
et a follow aussi LeStream sur Twitter, les liens sont dans la description.
J'espere que tout les jours vous viendrez vite fait sur LeStream voir les programmes du jour, voir ce qu'il s'y fais et que ca vous plaira.
Portez vous bien, tchao tout le monde.....
LeStream.fr
*chanson de fin*